je suis timide quand on applaudit pas je
peux pas monter sur scène
merci
alors certains ont compris d'autres non
j'ai pas besoin de me présenter je crois
que mon nom est déjà là
Marianne guesson
et c'est un plaisir pour moi d'être là
avec vous aujourd'hui
alors j'ai voulu commencer par cette
petite phrase anglaise tout simplement
pour que vous m'entendiez parler et
j'espère que comme vous m'avez entendu
parler vous n'avez pas senti un petit
mot français
parce que la plupart du temps je suis
plaisir là qu'on me demande ouais you
from et je le plaisir de répondre Côte
d'Ivoire et on me demande
et je suis contente
vous savez
je viens d'une famille modeste comme on
l'a dit mais quand on dit modeste on n'y
voit rien c'est family c'est compliqué
on était quatre on dit c'est pas
beaucoup mais il y avait les frères de
papa les frères de maman les cousins les
cousines à la maison donc c'était foutou
avec la sauce à midi la même sauce avec
du riz le soir et puis samedi par
l'extraordinaire un poulet braisé ou un
poisson braisé c'était ce jour-là sinon
c'était ressources
alors pourquoi je commence par dire ça
parce que
on m'a demandé comment est-ce que tu as
pu étudier en Grande-Bretagne pendant 6
ans quand tu dis que tu viens d'une
famille modeste comment est-ce que tu as
pu être là-bas
je vais répondre à cette question
aujourd'hui
quand j'étais en
CP2
ma mère a un frère qui est professeur
d'anglais élégant comme tout et qui
s'exprime mais de façon merveilleuse en
anglais et c'est donc là m'a donné
l'amour de la langue étant dans une
école primaire publique
bien évidemment il y avait pas
l'enseignement de l'anglais dans cette
école et donc chaque vacances je me
faisais le plaisir d'aller chez mon
oncle qui donnait des cours de vacances
et j'étais dans sa classe à un moment
j'étais devenue enseignante assistante
je l'ai déjà préparé les cours mais
j'attendais d'arriver en 6e tout
simplement pour avoir accès à l'anglais
et quand je suis arrivé en 6e c'était le
premier cours que j'attendais le cours
d'anglais je me suis accroché j'ai
appartenu au club d'anglais et je n'ai
pas lâché jusqu'à la fin quand j'ai eu
mon BTS j'ai dit à mes parents je vais
aller étudier en Grande-Bretagne mon
père venait d'aller à la retraite ma
mère était seule avec son salaire
d'enseignante à gérer toute la famille
ils m'ont regardé ils m'ont dit Marianne
sincèrement on t'aime de tout l'amour du
monde mais on peut pas t'envoyer en
Grande-Bretagne on n'a pas les moyens je
leur ai dit on va trouver donc j'appelle
le tonton qui entre-temps avait pu aller
aux États-Unis qui dit à ma mère je sais
que c'est là si tu la fais partir en
Grande-Bretagne elle va se débrouiller
elle dit mais on trouve l'argent où donc
les tontons les tantir les cousins
vraiment au cotise et ils peuvent à
cette époque là rassembler un million
qui faisait 1000 livres
je m'en vais en Grande-Bretagne je leur
ai dit envoyez-moi seulement s'il y a
pas l'argent qui vient ensuite envoyer
seulement
à l'entretien quand je vais à
l'ambassade on me demande vous avez
besoin d'un interprète je dis non la
dame regarde avec un homme méchant et tu
as pas besoin d'interprète je lui dis
non j'ai pas besoin d'interprète donc je
converse avec le monsieur il me regarde
comme ça
pas mal mais pourquoi vous l'aller en
Grande-Bretagne je lui dis mais quand tu
entends mon accent et tu entends ton
accent c'est le même il me dit non je
dis c'est l'accent que je recherche je
m'en vais et je reviens avec l'accent il
me dit je vous donne 6 mois je lui donne
deux jours
il me donne six mois j'arrive quand
j'arrive je fais le test de langue on me
dit votre niveau est très bon donc on
vous met en advance du coup au lieu de
faire un an de cours avant d'aller
m'inscrire je fais six mois de cours
club d'anglais merci
réduction de coûts quand j'arrive on me
dit que les francophones font des petits
bureaux clinique nettoyage et tout et je
vais faire ces cliniques et tout ça j'ai
pas d'ouverture je vais dans un McDo on
dit au McDo il faut faire cuire des McDo
et tout ça avant d'arriver à la caisse
je dis moi en général j'aime pas la
cuisine donc vraiment j'ai pas fait
frire de McDo donc j'arrive je discute
avec le patron il me dit mais vous avez
un très bel accent vous avez un très bon
niveau vous venez d'où je dis de la Côte
d'Ivoire il me dit ah bon mais je vous
mets en caisse un peu d'espagnol j'ai
jamais fait cuire un seul burger en tant
que francophone et nouvelle aux grandes
Bretagne j'ai travaillé à la caisse
et j'étais dans un dans une gare donc du
coup j'avais les gens qui parlent
français des gens qui parlent anglais et
les gens qui parlent espagnol donc le
peu d'espagnol que j'ai appris mon frère
ça m'a permis de travailler à la caisse
un moment j'avais mal aux pieds parce
que je peux pas rester debout donc je
dis bon qu'est-ce que je vais faire ce
que je vais faire c'est que je vais
aller tourner dans la salle non je dis à
mes amis écoutez je tourne dans la salle
de restauration parce qu'il y avait une
star les gens mangent donc je tourne
dans la salle je regarde les enfants je
parle aux parents comment ça va le
burger c'est bien et tout ça et mon boss
me regardait
[Musique]
grâce à ma maîtrise de l'anglais
je finis tout ce parcours je vais aller
à l'université j'arrive à me dire vous
avez un BTS et le BTS il va rien
malheureusement ici n'est pas reconnu
donc il faut que vous puissiez
normalement vous reprenez je discute
avec le directeur des études je dis non
oui snowpoint
il me regarde il me dit
à cause de ton niveau de langue au lieu
de commencer en première année on te met
en dernier parce que quand on regarde tu
pourras suivre donc on me met en
dernière année pour faire le Bachelor
plutôt que de faire la première année
donc du coup
j'ai moins de coup pour mon cours
d'anglais il est réduit 2 j'ai du boulot
avec interaction et beaucoup mieux payé
que les autres boulots tout simplement
parce que je peux interagir avec les
gens 3 au niveau de mon Master pardon de
mon cours Bachelor au lieu de commencer
la première année on me dit à cause du
niveau de langue on peut me mettre en
troisième année
je viens d'une famille pour laquelle les
gens ont cotisé pour m'envoyer ils ont
donné un million qui faisait 1000 livres
et rien à suivi ensuite pendant toutes
ces années j'ai travaillé pour pouvoir
payer mes cours mais j'ai pu le faire
tout simplement parce que j'ai pu
démontrer cette maîtrise de la langue
qui m'a donné des boulots qui étaient un
peu mieux payés et qui m'ont permis de
pouvoir continuer à payer mes cours mais
quand je finis tout ça que je rentre en
Côte d'Ivoire et quand je participe à
certains programmes et je me rends
compte que c'est que des enfants de
famille huppés qui ont accès à anglais
ils n'ont pas de Tonton professeur
d'anglais qui peut insister ou essayer
de galvaniser des personnes pour les
accompagner
c'était en 2002 2003 quand je partais à
je suis revenue en 2009 aujourd'hui en
2023 les choses sont beaucoup plus
difficiles
la vie est beaucoup plus chère peut-être
qu'il y a pas un tonton peut-être qu'il
y a pas une tata mais on a l'influence
des réseaux sociaux comme notre frère
Maxwell vient de dire et donc de par ce
que je sais faire de parce que je
connais je commence à m'illustrer dans
des programmes d'échanges dieu merci en
2016 je suis sélectionnée pour le
programme Mandela Washington felo on
fait beaucoup de tapage avec ma courte
Roselyne qui assise là à Stéphane on
fait beaucoup de tapage pour que les
gens sachent qu'en fait
tu n'as pas besoin de venir d'une
famille qui a beaucoup d'argent pour
avoir accès à quelque chose il faut que
quelqu'un te tende la main dans mon cas
ça a été le tonton qui a été là et je me
suis dit il faut que je crée quelque
chose il faut que je permette à ceux qui
n'ont pas réellement l'opportunité
d'avoir les moyens qu'il faut pour avoir
des cours d'anglais de pouvoir à quoi
accès à ça regardez ce que l'anglais a
pu faire pour moi quelle porte ça peut
m'ouvrir j'ai obtenu un Master je suis
revenu j'ai été demandé la Washington
vélo 2016 j'ai été chez vinning en 2021
tout simplement parce que j'ai cette
maîtrise de la langue du coup depuis
2018 je me dis il faut que je fasse
quelque chose
il faut que je fasse quelque chose il
faut que j'inspire des gens il faut que
les gens se disent peut-être qu'il faut
qu'ils voient quelqu'un qui vient d'une
famille où il y a pas grand chose pour
qu'il se dise je peux faire ça aussi
donc en 2018 je crée la Fondation Mirane
fondation je me dis il faut faire
quelque chose je commence à accompagner
des clopes d'anglais je commence à
soutenir des jeunes et puis on peut
faire encore de jeunes filles on
rassemble une vingtaine de filles
pendant trois semaines on fait venir un
professeur des États-Unis qui les forme
aujourd'hui ces filles là sont à
l'université beaucoup d'entre elles il y
en a qui sont allés au Canada qui ont pu
avoir des besoins on a continué comme ça
après je me suis dit il faut que je
touche un peu plus de personnes on crée
une page Facebook et on commence à
partager des informations je dis il faut
qu'on aille dans des écoles et des
écoles publiques donc on voit dans des
écoles publiques et on essaie de faire
aimer la langue aux enfants elle a dit
tout à l'heure il était une fois elle a
dit cesser et ce que je fais avec les
enfants c'est du conte once on a time
time et on raconte des histoires et avec
le compte les enfants s'approprient la
langue et commence à aimer un moment je
me dis il faut que je fasse quelque
chose de plus fort je veux une maison
une maison linguistique une maison dans
laquelle des enfants et des jeunes de
famille défavorisées peuvent se donner
le droit de rentrer sans payer grand
chose et d'avoir accès à cette langue
qui demeure des portes
je viens de Bingerville comme Nadine
et heureusement il y a une maison j'en
parle à ma mère je dis est-ce qu'on peut
pas utiliser elle me dit a vraiment
c'est des trucs en location de famille
et tout ça
je peux avoir la maison mais délabré
comme tout donc je commence des
réparations par ci des rénovations par
là je veux que ce soit parfait parce que
j'aime les choses parfaites et donc on
décale l'ouverture on décale à un moment
je dis Marianne
un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu auras
ouvre
on se lève on ouvre dans le quartier de
Blachon a un quartier de pauvre mais on
ouvre et on met un peu de musique et on
dit aux enfants venez apprendre anglais
les parents s'arrêtent ils regardent ils
disent ça là ça doit être cher
et les parents qui disent les enfants
alors enfants faut pas partir il n'est
pas l'argent pour payer
ou bien qui me disent ne donne pas de
faux espoirs à ses enfants parce que où
ils vont pouvoir partir je me suis
assise j'ai pleuré j'ai dû ne donne pas
de faux espoirs mais il faut que les
gens entendent mon histoire il faut
qu'il sache de quelle famille je viens
il faut qu'il sache comment est-ce que
je suis arrivé où je suis aujourd'hui
grâce à l'anglais donc je commence à
partager avec les parents je vais de
porte à pois je leur dis je suis né ici
j'ai grandi ici moi je suis né à
Bingerville j'ai grandi à Bingerville
deux enfants trois enfants il y a deux
semaines samedi on a dit on ouvre j'ai
mon mentor qui m'appelle d'Angleterre
elle me dit Marianne j'ai vu ce que tu
fais sur Facebook et je veux t'aider
envoie-moi ton budget
je lui envoie mon budget et puis je
m'assuélie comme ça je sais même pas si
à trois jours de l'événement elle m'a
appelé
Tin Tin Tin Tin Tin je regarde sur mon
téléphone elle m'a donné le budget de
l'ouverture du samedi dernier elle dit
j'ai confiance en toi vas-y je sais que
tu peux le faire j'ai commencé à pleurer
jeudi mais est-ce que c'est possible que
quelqu'un de mon backgroun qui vient de
je ne sais où peut se lever rêver
d'avoir une maison pour des enfants
défavorisés et quelqu'un va voir quelque
part il va dire je peux
on a fait l'ouverture samedi on a
commencé à 13h parce que à 10h il a
commencé à pleuvoir il a plu des cordes
tout le monde m'a dit Marianne il pleut
il faut annuler il faut reporter les
enfants viendront pas les gens viendront
pas
moi je suis chrétienne et j'ai froid
quand je fais quelque chose quand je le
ressens profondément au fond de moi même
si j'ai pas le moyen les choses se
déroulent et ça se fait je me suis mise
à genoux je regardais celui qui m'a
demandé de faire je lui ai dit tu m'as
dit d'ouvrir je vais ouvrir
il faut que les enfants viennent
on avait 7 enfants on est sorti quand la
pluie s'est calmer sur le terrain on a
mis la musique j'ai raconté mon histoire
Once Upon a Time jusqu'à ce qu'on
finisse l'histoire on était à 25 enfants
quand on a fini qu'on est rentré pour
faire les activités de cuisine et de
bijoux
quand on a fini à 17h on avait 45
enfants
45 enfants et jeunes de cette zone là
[Applaudissements]
à 17h on a dû chasser les enfants et
fermer la porte
quand j'en suis sorti le lendemain les
parents m'appellent teacher Annie
teacher
[Musique]
parce que tous les enfants ont entendu
hello hello hello teacher hello hello
hello tea
le lendemain dans le quartier quand je
passais j'entendais Élodie
hello teacher ça semble quelque chose de
minime ça semble quelque chose de tout
petit mais quel est l'objectif
l'objectif est déjà d'initier dans le
cœur de ses enfants l'amour de cette
langue et de savoir que ça va ouvrir des
portes que des parents regardent et
m'entendent et disent si cette petite
fille de cette famille là a pu arriver
ici si on donne l'opportunité à nos
enfants on ne sait jamais il y a des
bourses gratuites mais tout ce qu'il
faut c'est parler anglais il y a des
programmes d'échange gratuit tout ce
qu'il faut c'est parler anglais déjà
dans des familles modestes c'est
difficile d'avoir accès à une formation
si on peut avoir une bourse grâce à une
langue pourquoi pas
la maison linguistique des enfants
défavorisés c'est de pouvoir les ouvrir
dans les endroits de toute la Côte
d'Ivoire ou ses enfants là nos rêves
même pas entendre un jour parler anglais
et mon rêve est de pouvoir arriver dans
ses différents petits logos comme on dit
chez nous et de permettre à ces enfants
merveilleux et formidables qui ont tout
ce qu'il faut pour avoir cette
opportunité de s'ouvrir au monde d'avoir
accès
j'ai commencé avec le premier centre de
Bingerville et je sais une chose c'est
45 enfants que j'ai eu ce jour-là
n'arrêteront pas de venir et à partir de
ce centre je suis sûre qu'on aura
d'autres au centre tout simplement parce
que il y a des personnes qui entendent
qui voient et qui savent l'importance de
la langue et qui savent qu'il faut
donner des chances à tous ceux pour qui
ce n'est pas facile à tous ceux pour qui
ce n'est pas donné ce n'est pas aisé d'y
avoir accès je suis Marianne guesson je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]